you have a daughter now who's a year old
16 months am i can't be here those
people I know you know I don't do the
months I've had two children and I'm
always asking people have Walden they're
like my child is seventy four months I
know I know I take it back
she's a year old I'm sorry I'm 7,000
months old it's my birthday every day um
I apologize no no I'm sorry I got it so
I'm sorry
acting like a crazy producer uh it now
is she talking a lot cuz I remember one
year is when they start to say
interesting things she is talking about
we didn't know cuz we have one and we've
never really been around babies so we
know nothing we're so dumb but we took
her to the doctor and he asked how many
words and we were prepared we knew he
was gonna ask so we counted and we told
him I think he'd be like okay and he
said that's actually that's a that's a
lot of words for courage Sean I think so
she but some of them we cheated because
some of them are compound words um white
wine is she said your daughter says
white wine and he says white wine and
she points to hers and she's like white
wine and I'm like let's not in public
right and she also shuts not a good sign
no but she she know we she knows we
laugh when she says it so she knows and
she pauses for laughs right I know we're
yeah we're anyway it's not you got a
Martin Short on your hand
morphine farm brother choice yeah yeah
you